part two
of
programmer humor so i ended the first
video because it was starting to get
kind of long and then i scrolled down a
little bit and i was like oh here's all
the good ones here's
it actually gets good once we you get
really far down the subreddit all the
top ones are trash
ah
being popular sucks
apparently
why is popular stuff never good well not
never but you know
anyway let's go
part two reacting to these memes web
development be like beginner website
html intermediate website html css
javascript advanced website
all this stuff expert just javascript
i don't know
okay every team project has someone like
this
yes yes it seems like it
um
it reminds me of senior design
uh there's me
there's uh there's max there's that's
ashley and there's there's han
yeah we know han we know
all right my developer and stand up
today i get an error each time so i'm
making progress
oh a guy must be i hate the life right
now
less than helpful
the docs were written by someone who
already knows the system or by someone
who didn't bother to find out
uh going from angular 2 to to react
going from react to angular 2.
okay
so stuck plow to tiny tricycle awesome
motorcycle two awesome car
shouldn't be
this going to this or so i don't know
seems
seems like
okay sucks going from angular 2 to react
sucks going from react angular 2 is
just awesome either way i don't know i
don't get the meme because i don't use
much reactor angular 2 but
evolution of naming your very rules
first name last name
f name last name you see i don't like
fname
l name because
it's not clear what could it be it could
be anything it could be final name loser
name you know it's not clear
fn
ln
fl
a b
unpopular opinion i think this is the
only good one
f and l are definitely terrible
f and ln are definitely definitely
terrible a b a b is pretty good actually
because
it represents order
of going from a to b so you kind of have
the first and last relationship and it
could be anything
of first second first last so the only
good ones are the first one and the last
one in my opinion
job application
wrote a cool program called job
application function i need a job for
experience return you need experience
for this job
so it calls this one you need experience
for this job
any experience
for this job return i need experience i
need a job for experience
so just recursively goes back and forth
forever
and they just call it oh god
why why is this why did can we just stop
putting you need x years of experience
on every job
posting
like the amount of people that cuts out
that are great for the job is not very
fair and yeah they're they're always
going to have this problem of look i
can't get the job because i don't have
experience and i can't get experience
because i can't get the job because you
require experience even
yeah it's it's it's sort of a problem
trying to understand the windows api
yeah that's about how i feel like d word
wait why do you bother with d word can
it
can it just can we just use okay
nevermind
yep that happened when you accidentally
get check out the wrong file the sacred
text
it's all this message in devops channel
this morning how to make a meme
the support of a product is about to
expire don't really care
the end of life health check has failed
in your system yeah
okay
more promoted crap all right when you
compile your code and get over 999 error
and 600 warnings
uh
it's funny face but i'm not
yeah it's probably about the face you
make
when i drag files to the trash bin
they're not getting deleted help
oh my gosh poor adam
developed by github
can't beat any other editor and
anything ever
i don't know that's not that bad of an
editor they're just better ones
python one liner
thousand lines
c library
all right not that funny
i'm a bad bug
oh yeah
what's new so
so you're a bad bug maker user sad bug
opposite of rad bug glitch like it's a
fad bug
were those good devs code like we should
devs get under the hood devs
like we said we would devs can we fix
some bugs
that's the best update
uh
version update ever
not declared variable me type new
variable name
i love it
just receive this on jira
yeah
issue a sign do you remove fascist
queries
what
all right
tries to write a recursive function my
application kellogg's infinite loops
oh that's good
what i did today and i'm proud
using code from stack overflow
using code from stack overflow and
renaming variables
see the rest using code from stack
overflow renaming variables and mix it
into your coworker's code
mix it with your coworker's code using
code from stack overflow renaming
variables mix them with your codeworks
code and adding some a trim somewhere
all right
yeah that's usually how it goes
literally had
never had to post on stack overflow
new software technology launches this is
so tiny what's this image so tiny
the ancients going to stack overflow to
ask every
question imagine okay
all right
if you're a compiler
look away now so a friend of mine sent
me some code a colleague of his
abc
actually nothing will happen the whole
code block is skipped probably for the
best now we'll loop endlessly as a
condition will always be true
i didn't notice it's an assignment
oh i see
yeah the this thing right here is the
problem i was looking at it forever it
should be equals equals
to for comparison otherwise every time
it hits this it's just going to assign x
to 3
and go to this again sign x to three
again go to this again assign x to three
yeah it's just gonna infinitely do case
three
okay well that's not
it's not that uncommon of a error for
people to make so
whatever
okay i think we've got past all the good
ones a few more you
you cannot use kubernetes people who use
kubernetes
wish they didn't
and the people who don't wish they did
it's been about a year and a half since
i moved out of sre what did i miss
programmers when they attempt to go
outside oh god relatable
relatable last one
no one more we got we got one down here
that has a lot of upvotes so maybe it's
good when you see an unassigned epic
just
start adding times and logic to your
project you just got done with your
previous task
oh man
still an entrepreneur
when you work on a game for five years
and only seven people buy it
and this i'm selling that
oh man i hope this doesn't turn into my
life
all right
this episode brought to you by
spam on the internet
two 27.99 a month frontier internet
if it's available in your area you can
get slow unreliable internet with crappy
modems
and maybe you'll be able to watch
youtube video every once in a while and
possibly upload something every once in
a while most likely you're just going to
get disconnected a lot thank you
frontier for not sponsoring this video
consider sponsoring this video and i'll
say something good about you consider
having good internet and i'll say
something good about you alright see you
guys in the next episode of whatever i
decide to make next peace out